there has been a lot of talk on Ayers
wimby the best Prospect since LeBron
I've saw some people say he's the best
Prospect ever of course everyone's going
to say that now but let's not forget how
big of a prospect LeBron James was
LeBron James was Athena from 15 years
old LeBron James was the number one pick
as a 15 year old so although we like to
move on fast to the next thing I'm just
not going off the rail and saying he's a
better Prospect than LeBron however he
is probably definitely the best Prospect
since LeBron and probably the second
best Prospect ever also we tend to
forget what type of prospect LeBron was
because he did the unthinkable what we
thought of him as a prospect he actually
outlived and outdid what we thought of
him as a prospect so it's very easy now
in today's day and age to say oh he's a
better Prospect than LeBron because you
forget how big of a prospect LeBron was
because of how much he's done but LeBron
was a huge crazy Prospect